ciao ragazzi benvenuti alla seconda
puntata di pesce d'aprile
allora la scorsa puntata è stata pregna
di emozioni abbiamo riso cioè hanno riso
io basito hashtag basito tutto il tempo
speriamo che adesso che riprenderemo ad
ascoltare messaggi le cose migliorino
mi impegnerò ragazzi no che non possiamo
iniziare cosmetici per i nomi bizzarri
di nostra morena rendete conto che qui
parliamo di dei vestiti matera
sensibilizziamo le persone fuori versi
più bene
ma come si può correre bene una versione
come voi io vi chiedo scusa perché
assolutamente assolutamente sono i
contenuti più alti a più alti e basta
anche tipo in uso al tema del citofono
sarebbe stato finale dato che periti
ammette io voglio più sentir raccontare
fila scherzo che piaceva il pesce
d'aprile ad una mia amica mandare a roma
con la macchina io dietro la macchina li
ho attaccato questo biglietto con
scritto suonare se volete
non ti dico tutta la strada quante o
quante fresco nelle suonava nelle
carriere che è stato e dopo quel viaggio
la sua amica non è bene che io prima
sentivo dal bagno che ridevate per un
pesce d'aprile dello scen
la bella nota tranquilla quella realtà
cioè con questa ragazza
date la prima è andata una cena di
classe in cui si sta questa ragazza con
cui ero già stato insieme le tabelle ci
stava e non volevo andarci io ci andai
lo stesso
e siccome giorno lavora delle palme che
ha scavato sul primo aprile ho detto io
faccio uno scherzo andato alla tutto il
tempo lo a milano quando lo incontra le
faccio parlare e ho detto a francesca di
do parlare noi ho detto neanche amore ci
siamo messi a progetti da ringhiera
guardiamo avanti
gli dico guarda ieri stava serena ho
bevuto un po lei a un certo punto
mandato un bacio lo scansata attimo di
pausa no per fare un po lo spettro 30
secondi in silenzio linfa e mi faccio io
non ottenesse una certezza
c'era rimasta malissimo questa cosa non
sapevo che fare
lei non risponde mi giro con le guance
rigate di lacrime no e io scoppiano a
ridere se lei va genova per un piccione
in faccia perché lo ricordo che ho fatto
un male che le faccia pure karate quindi
fatto bene in realtà non era vero niente
no era vero poi la cosa che fa ridere ma
beh questa non l'ammetteranno visti ad
aprile
non si può mettere ragazzi stiamo
veramente tornando alle medie questo
video è perfetto per tutte le persone
che hanno dai 12 anni
io odio gli scherzi ma anche se ti fanno
se mi vendico peggio però rido rido
tanto la moderna e divertente vedere la
persona sofferente
tu hai fatto uno scherzo assurdo della
mano terribile ero a casa armare di un
video che mi aveva invitato per milano
in camere separate
credo ha raccontato che vedevo da una
certa ora non dormiva c'era la luce
accesa e di che faccio mi avvicino per
vedere cosa stesse facendo e lo vedevo
con l'ipod fortuna perché vorrei beccare
molto peggio che decido allora di gap
arrivare ha risolto il suo letto che era
vicino alla porta finestra aperta quindi
deciso di sbattere la porta finestra per
vedere una frazione no ma niente allora
le chiedi del suo letto c'era un altro
letto con le rotelle
credo la giusta idea di andare che di
dell'ex scuotere violentemente letto con
le rotelle rotelle e si vede lui è
iniziata sulle si stava addosso il tempo
che è sceso dal letto io gli ho
afferrato la caviglia e è morto perché è
caduto sul comodino
allora ciao che già ospite allora
fumi non fa ridere virus buttata ciao
che già ospita allora lo scherzo di
quindi andrò a parlare
l'ha fatto mia mamma a me al mio
fratello e mia nonna mia mamma va al
bagno non avendo niente di meglio da
fare decine di truccarsi facendosi un
occhio nero
ovviamente essendo solo in bagno non la
vediamo lei prende un flacone di shampoo
quando ha finito non lancia per terra e
si piange per finta non è realmente sa
intanto questo sarà un posto che mi
bagna troviamo buttata per terra chandon
ha sbattuto sbattuto si toglie la mano
questo occhio nero io comincio a
piangere perché con quella piccolina
avevo una decina d'anni mio fratello 41
di mediano alla spaventatissima comincia
a tua madre orribile famiglie di 17 anni
ha capito con un occhio fuori di rumor e
voci dal flacone quando cadeva per terra
che ha abbaiato rumore strano perché un
cane
pensavo se flacone
anticervicale infla care
siamo a livello di una cam e gianmarco
che sta succedendo ma tu sei connesso
con me mi sono un po cede al fascino
ok a canne e questo stronzo ai ragazzi
dico solo io sono mortificato io vi
chiedo perdono tutto opposto stai
fattore grecia ospiterà la terza volta
che prova a fare questo messaggio
prospero che sia quella buona per quanto
riguarda gli sketch fici e altre mete
coinquilina abbiamo deciso di
[Musica]
in casa che è stata fatta di seta può
essere che quella con claudio dire sì
forse la sera che non bisogna farle
basile sta impazzendo di nuovo allora
vediamo se riusciamo sentirla questo
messaggio che la quarta volta
ciao ciao a spit e la terza volta che
prova a fare questo messaggio quindi
spero che sia quella buona per quanto
riguarda gli scherzi e pc e altri miti
coinquiline abbiamo deciso di ricoprire
la stanza di un'altra nostra coinquilina
con la carta d'alluminio ricoprivamo
ogni cosa ci capitasse sottomano quindi
il cuscino deodorante smalti carta
d'identità
volevamo fare le cose bene abbiamo
deciso di ricoprire le entrate della sua
porta con la carta trasparente
peccato che ci abbia esclamato e adesso
ne sto ancora su vendere conseguenze io
mi ricordo la carta igienica ovunque
verrà samp bellissimo colpito
completamente tutta la stanza di carta
igienica bianco ma poi fatta bene non
buttava quella proviamo fatto il filo
bene che andava d'affetto tornare ma due
anni e poi sta a cuore da quell'altra
barbari che facevate quel mahdavi a un
certo punto non riusciamo a dormire per
la pozione promette di asciugamani avevo
le foto con l'uno eliminare
ma schivo che scrivo ragazzi io sono
mortificato ma queste c'è io non è che
posso cacciarlo via queste persone
soggette alla mia famiglia
sono imbarazzato ciao cuccia ospite e
sarà mia madre che mi venivano a
svegliare tutti i giorni per andare a
scuola è un giorno il primo d'aprile
ho deciso di fare questo scherzo lei mi
era svegliare in un balzo del letto mi
chiamo mi chiamo mediano ma niente
accende la luce niente non mi sveglio
abbassa la serranda non mi sveglia a un
certo punto mi agita nel letto io
continuo a far finta di non svegliarmi
alla reputa tranquilla mi apri gli occhi
con con le dita ho rivoltato io è che lì
appeso o infarto ne ha quasi messo a
piangere e gridando che cosa abbiamo
fatto e morto arrivato mio padre vuole
tutti eccitati alle 21
nessun aprile e non di raggiungere le
botte che ho preso bene anche nel varo
anche giustamente è morto l'hanno ucciso
mia madre me lo rinfaccia ancora
dicendomi che stata l'unica volta il
papa paura sì ma tua madre dovrà
ucciderti meno male che non sarò mai
madre ma veramente non avevamo più
nessuna persona malavita buttata a
questo punto prendo chiunque
venite tutti quanti a casa mia lo shen
non ho il rigo arrivo è nato sta ridendo
dall'inizio hanno fatto allora
praticamente simile mese do merito con
te ti faccio vedere una persona
questo è uno scherzo molto divertente
molto semplice praticamente se questo
qui il materasso è questo qui è lenzuolo
rimboccato sopra con sopra il copriletto
che io quindi tu hai il copriletto
il lenzuolo sopra letto ok il prendi
lenzuolo lo infili sotto al letto
togli il piumone ed alghe del letto lo
tiri su lo coprì con il piumone in modo
che chi entra dentro praticamente non
riesce a entrare perché fa un effetto
sacco ora non sa quanto abbiate capito
non lo fanno
[Risate]
e mi vedevo mio fratello gabriele diceva
strano ma tutti d'accordo che niente la
tra le loro hanno alzato di nascosto il
copriletto non sfondato il suolo era un
pannolone del cio quali gambe che erano
entrate nel lettone ho sfondato con il
sacco non ha funzionato che tu non ti
n'è accorto di niente tutto il mio
numero io non mi sono accorto che
avevano praticamente non tira d'accordo
aver rotto se no non mi sono
addormentato non ne ho idea se come non
l'avevano fatto bene avere un solo
misurato tirargli le unghie dei piedi
con tutti e rigo stava cercando di dire
che questo video sarà quasi muto che
sembra charlie chaplin
stai perdendo il senno lacan l'omonimo
dato che se la tiene più assurdo l'ho
fatto al mio compagno l'ho distrutto in
una sola giornata non sapeva più se stai
con me uccidermi
gli ho messo il dato knorr il soffione
della doccia non mandato al lavoro che
praticamente puzzava di prodotti che
arrivano al lavoro aperto la coca cola
vi avevo legato lamento sconfino
interdetta era una volta aperto il tappo
la gente è scesa in fondo alla botte e
coca cola ed è stata su tutto su tutti i
modi e una volta uscito fuori con roma
alcuni colleghi di lavoro gli avevo
chiuso la macchina in mezzo ai carrelli
della spesa cioè lui è uscito con le
mani nei capelli non sapeva più cosa
fare volevo uccidere detto questo ti
faccio tanti saluti
sei il numero uno veramente telling
super permessi
bastico se si vota il primo video non
smetterò mai di seguirti bacio ciao
grazie mille si stata gentilissima e
sono contento di starti simpatico anche
tutte le persone dei quali pure bene
finiscono male quindi spero di non
incontrarlo team a tutte le persone
intorno a te stanno morendo
anche il tuo cane entrambe dovendo
comunque leader razzi si cioè grandi
meriti conto che cosa ha fatto
guarda che lega la mente è
difficilissimo e che ho amato tantissimo
il numero zero
affittasi semplificatore ragazzi siamo
arrivati alla fine di questa tragedia e
non vi voglio mai più bene a nessuno di
voi a casa mia
aspettatevi una secchiata d olio
bollente dal balcone e poi da mark
peggio di noi ed a dirla tutta perché no
io so contenere livello di enrico
sicuramente già marco secondo me pure
cani in calore sono a contenere marito
di enrico io ti ringrazio la scena per
questo contributo unico che è dato a
questa rubrica che altro aggiungere a
dio
comunque a parte gli scherzi grazie
mille per essere venuto qui grazie a voi
per aver resistito fino a questo momento
siete veramente stati molto molto forti
fateci sapere quali sono stati magari
che ne so degli scherzi simpatici che
avete fatto o anche semplicemente per
insultare le scene rico e per il loro
humour becero che dire iscrivetevi come
sempre lasciate un libro che non
lasciate un mi piace lasciato mi piace
alla nostra vita quella è la cosa più
importante però se non volete perdere
altri video attivate anche la campagnia
qua sotto a noi ci vediamo la prossima
settimana con un altro vita buttata ciao
ciao tiro grazie definita bravo spegnere
e quasi poetico amico
sipario